hello and welcome to this video Pisco
gambit let's seem okay and siding for
just being rock solid here instead of
taking pawns yeah why not that cannot be
a bad decision let's see what we get
here a three oh my god what's the point
before me yeah it seems it seems he is
basically happy with being a playing now
with playing them like black side of a
catalan with white so let's see b6 rook
e8 also comes into consideration maybe
do this one thing I know he is playing
rather quickly
p for you you don't want to play before
you're right he wants to play before
that looks crazy to be honest 93 looks
absolutely terrible so see fire wins
material but is that really enough
taking on beef is also interesting c4
look take screen takes Bishop takes
Queen checks and I'm not immediately
winning the material okay so i can take
on before of course and then and then
play like we should be five very likely
that i had something stronger
it's very likely
and we had weird weird was so soon see
for maybe I should have still played see
for them yeah this is not not that great
iam I mean probably all right but after
after before you should be a should have
some kind of key advantage and not be
all right now to be 50 he wants to go
hmm
didn't expect that move at all okay but
it's interesting of course it's not bad
check I can take f2m not sure about it
can also do just this yeah it's like two
minutes at on the clock this is Sir the
main concern you of course grah ahead
you heard me a draw check check that
time wise it's not too great
oh wow then I didn't stare didn't see
it's a little bit annoying to put it
mildly
check now I catch this part-time morning
he wants to go g4 right let's get this
running check I still have quite some
time check which is good check check
check check check white resigns yeah I
shouldn't have won this game really but
yeah I would have taken the drawer that
actually just had played the move and
then I thought okay maybe I can actually
do something I really I really quite
annoyed that I didn't manage to refute
this before stuff it looks awful
absolutely awful the computer I mean
okay completely gifts like a CLE edge
but I did not think about this move at
all and it makes perfect sense it
prepares to see for idea this is on yeah
this is pretty good young bishop d5 is a
good good idea yeah this is refuting
this wild idea and this isn't this isn't
all that great now he's fine of course
now maybe he also was better that that
this is very much like him check yeah of
course I can take f2 now which I wanted
to I wanted to play on this night c 6
a-5 idea he never played it yeah we
should just you should check end in a
draw horse check still and it was lucky
I didn't see and see that idea here at
all and now this is this could be
critical for black somehow i mean i
don't know i mean winning is is
completely out of it out of them
out of the question normally at Kings
Kings afore was wasn't helping this is
may be interesting him the problem here
is some kind of suits fine for example
if I play this move yeah and he plays um
kingi form it's not quite sure what I
should do if Chad will check he goes
back and something something like that
check is probably winning h 4g form and
at the end he will get the pawn her f
was probably good Jackie here now I went
to King f5 and now we can't win with
takes at f/4 talking f5 was pretty
terrible choices a draw of course ah no
I simply I that wasn't totally totally
weird idea he cannot go up of course
because I take and threaten f5 mate so
then he has to go back and i still
cannot play this maybe and take things
therefore no no I'm okay now I'm okay
who then that only leaves would be six I
mean not mkay I can't play that okay
okay okay Kim Wow very tricky but what
didn't work is this not know I'm winning
so that was he was just playing in turbo
mode the whole game and the moment I
played quickly i blundered immediately
so yeah thinking a little bit usually
this help ok guys thanks for watching